hill it's under couch here and this time
today's a video we're going to be going
over
three levels of dashboards so i had this
idea
inspired from like buzzfeed's uh worth
it series where they go through like
three different foods at three different
price ranges and um i wanted to make
basically three different dashboards
that you would expect to see um
a simple you know five minute dashboard
a standard you know hour-long or
two-hour dashboard
and then a third one which is going to
be you know a very time consuming
a clean dashboard this is actually only
to uh
the the last dashboard that i created or
the more complicated one
is it only took me about two hours to
make where it's essentially
the the dashboard that we've already
created but i've added a few things to
make it a little bit nicer
so i figured this would be kind of a
cool video to show
um people who are making shiny
dashboards you know how they can improve
it
or how fast you can make it so you can
decide
you know how much work you're gonna put
into a dashboard or a given project
so i'm gonna show you first um the
simpler dashboard
um before we actually go through the
code we're not actually gonna do a lot
of coding
in this video because i i already did
the code and honestly
most of the coding is pretty boring it's
just copying pasting you know
charts um so that's not very interesting
it's pretty straightforward it's more
about like
design choices um and your data and what
you want to actually show to
you know your stakeholders um so this is
my
first dashboard and it's a pretty simple
one
um it's it's pretty static it just has
like a fighters
um oh yeah and the actual datas i'm
using for this uh
uh these three dashboards is a ufc data
set containing like
fighters like fight stats so like wins
losses
strikes knockdowns takedowns weight
class
you know etc um so this this dashboard
took me literally five minutes to create
uh there's no
code basically at all it's basically
showing a little table
of the fighter table that i have a
little chart showing like strikes landed
versus
strikes received for both the strikes
and takedowns
you can kind of see that um
what i think is uh pretty useful when
you're creating these like very simple
fast dashboards
is not using using just the regular
table function
using data table that way it's more
interactive where it's kind of like
almost an excel style table
uh you can also search so if i say i
don't know
ute right you just so it'll filter for
the fighter
by typing like zero it'll find um
um samples with zeros in it and stuff
like that
i also added all the standard weight
class uh so we can change the weight
class if you want to you know see how
these
people change um so yeah it's basically
just a static page
there's only about two things a chart
and a table with a little filtering
um and yeah so this the main things that
i was doing is
you know doing some data i'm wrangling
some cleaning so
creating wins losses so i could do some
summarization of like total wins and
losses
um just some you know standard mutates
some selects
etc um i could probably just remove this
too i don't actually need it
um and then this is the actual dashboard
so right here i have a slider input
because i think dashboards are
good when they're pretty interactive so
adding some type of input
is pretty useful especially since we're
just looking at these um
these tables essentially so adding
a filter it seems pretty straightforward
for that
and then for my actual outputs and
visuals i just have one plot
and one data table which is literally
just a data frame
so we have this um honestly from this
code it looks a little complicated but
right here it's just showing you um
there's a much of a
guess uh um formatting that i apply to a
table so like removing the
um uh the underscores and stuff like
that
i'm creating them as integers instead of
just numeric so just like removing the
decimal places
um using str to title so we'll do like
kind of like
um uppercase for every word stuff like
that
so in reality it's really just a fighter
data frame
i'm in a little bit of calculations but
that's pretty straightforward and that
could actually be put into
this data frame right here so it's a
pretty simple
um table to create uh you can definitely
go more fancier but since this
this app literally took five minutes to
make i just wanted to create a quick one
and then for this it's just a standard
plot
um with a pivot longer so you're just
showing out the um
you know landed versus received and
creating a gg plot
so for this since it's such a quick um
dashboard you can see that there's not a
lot
of stuff that goes into it it's pretty
messy because i didn't really clean any
code
i didn't do any data wrangling really
beforehand to make it simpler
there's no documentation and there's
just not a lot of plots it's only two
components
essentially which is a data table and a
plot so this is an example of a very
simple
quick dashboard that you probably create
um
just in case if you wanted to show it to
someone like a colleague but not really
for like an actual full-on
product uh okay so i'm gonna go through
there and then go to
my average app and this app we've
actually seen before in our
in my past videos um it's essentially
the was it the
the ufc uh dashboard video
um i didn't change anything onto it um i
think this is a pretty
typical dashboard you would see uh
if you're sharing with people um for one
thing uh
if you know notice that this is not
actually using
um the shiny dash shiny template like
the default template of like the
that little color instead it has the
shiny dashboard template so
it looks a little bit cleaner because it
has these little headers
a little title um you can you can hide
the sidebar if you want
again we have a little bit cleaner um
interfaces our gt plots
look a bit nicer they make more sense
they're
also in um the
the page around the areas right
we also have multiple ways to filter so
we can filter by weight class
a catch weight we can do heavy weight um
we still have our table too
so that's kind of cool and we also can
adjust our uh our ego which will do
some interactions with our plots of like
you know ew
elo i guess scores
throughout the year and then with our
top five fighters for that weight cost
that's pretty cool additionally have
another
tab so this makes it a little bit more
complicated um generally when you're
having a dashboard there's gonna be
multiple pages
uh right here it's kind of cool because
it's showing like um
it's estimating the probability of a
fighter will win i'm using a
elo model and then you can choose your
fighters
um use your your weight class so there's
a lot of interactiveness
and for this this actual dashboard i
believe took me about
i think in the video about 30 minutes to
maybe an hour because i did some data
wrangling and stuff like that
uh but again it's it's a pretty nice
dashboard right because
there's tons of uses for it um i could
see someone spending like a decent
amount of time
kind of just like messing with it and
looking at some different things that
they find interesting when they're
looking at ufc stuff
so let's actually look at this code and
evaluate what makes this kind of
a little bit more advanced dashboard
over your typical
simple um like static table
so one of the things that we've been
doing is we added shiny dashboard to it
which is basically the framework for our
templates and stuff
we also have um some functions that are
kind of
all over the place so we have here which
is like create elo data
and this will create our ego data for
our eo model
additionally we have these sidebar menus
so right now
the actual ui looks a little bit
different and it's a little bit more
complex because
we have not only a page um but we also
have a
sidebar with different menu items that
will basically choose what page we want
to go to
additionally we have multiple pages so
and among these actual items in our body
this is probably where the most com
the most amount of complexity goes into
on these dashboards is that
we've had we've added multiple different
filtering options
and in our other filtering options such
as say like weight class and fighter
those are actually interacting with each
other so if i were to choose like
women's phantom weight then the fighters
would be
filtered out to you know fighters who
are in that weight class so
you're doing like a woman's bantamweight
filter you wouldn't be able to choose
like henry's a hudo
uh for f i had to have fighter because
those people would never fight
uh henry's hero would never fight a
female although i'm sure he's uh he's
trying to
as he's retired but it's stuff like that
where we're adding a little bit more
logic into our filtering just adding
more filtering options
and just adding more content in our
dashboard
so let's actually look at our server i
think with the ui
uh it looks a little more complex but
it's just
with the framework of shiny dashboard
you're always gonna have to use boxes
um i also added like fluid rows so it's
a little bit more organized so
my outputs like plots and tables are
stacked in an even row
um that i can customize so i think
that's something that you
that adds a little bit more complexity
and more formatting to it makes a little
bit nicer
but generally people do that also in
like simple dashboards like my previous
one
um previous one so let's actually look
at
this um these server functions and i'm
just gonna skim this right
now and just show you that one thing
right here
there's a lot of like redundant code in
this so
for the weight class selector um we can
see that they're basically copying
basically the same thing right so create
ego data and create yellow data
with like different um inputs that's
pretty redundant
um additionally it's just like
functionally uh not a good idea because
we're creating a lot of variables or
having to recreate a lot of variables
and even though create elo data is
pretty straightforward because i'm
essentially just like
uh stacking two um
tables together um when you're doing
something very complex
uh you generally don't wanna repeat that
process because it'll take a lot of
memory from your computer
it'll actually impact your your your
dashboard's uh performance so
you know it might lag a little bit when
you're clicking around filters it might
lag when you're changing tabs
and this right now doesn't lag very well
very much just because uh
he functions so fast because there's not
a lot of data that's being uh
wrangled but um this is a very
inefficient
dashboard uh if we're gonna have a lot
of people use it or if our data was
gonna get really large
but that's one thing that i'm just
seeing right now is we're doing a lot of
repeat
data creation uh so that's something
that we would want to fix if we were
doing something else
additionally there's some like um
functions where i'm basically selecting
the weight class
removing the duplicates and then sorting
by alphabetical order
that right here i do it a few times um
if you're going to be repeating the same
little function in this like
r script uh you should probably function
functionalize that too
so maybe i do like a clean clean
function right here
so it'll look a little bit nicer for uh
for the actual
um server side we'll keep on going
uh again they're just standard selectors
like i really like
this selector right here or it's just
using
our other um weight class to filter out
our
other selector for our fighter software
so our weight class selector
is being used to filter our fighter
suctor
okay and then right here we're just
using the radio table
um this is a pretty straightforward
thing right here
uh some plots some distributions
um and then one thing that we i think i
added that makes a little bit
makes the the the dashboard a little bit
more cleaner and
it kind of upgrades the quality of it is
like adding value boxes
i'm generally management and like um
like any type of management really likes
using
dashboards and they also like using like
value boxes so
all your boxes um are a good way to just
like
show literally the most important like
kpi or takeaway um generally you're not
trying to show
like very complex charts uh to upper
management people i don't even want to
look at plots so
having these value boxes or like radar
charts that are very simple
very easy to kind of get a measurement
of how a business or something is
operating is very important in this case
it's just
showing the probability of an opponent
winning
but that's kind of a good kind of way to
show you like okay
like this is the big thing that someone
should be looking at instead of just
tweaking all the other stuff
up for the analysis i will also say that
there's not a lot of commenting uh
there's no comment on this
uh this dashboard which i'm not sure for
me
i think you should probably or i should
have probably added more comments to
explain what i'm doing
but since this was from a video i i was
fine with not
doing any um insane documentation
because i have a video doing it
but if you're going to show or put our
training dashboard maybe into production
uh and that's going to be it'll be
worked on
it's something that you would have to
try to at least document and then
maybe even functionalize this okay
so that's it for the average dashboard
um and i think that's a typical
dashboard but then i also created
a like advanced dashboard that makes it
a little bit it fixes a lot of the
um voices that i did in my previous one
or the average dashboard
because the advanced dashboard basically
makes it a little bit more cleaner
to look at um both from a user
standpoint
so from people using the the dashboard
and
also from like a developer standpoint
so first thing that i want to show you
is i'm actually gonna
run the app and let's see if that'll pop
up it
so again there's nothing really changed
this is the same dashboard from the
average dashboard but uh i think a good
upgrade
for our shiny dashboards is having some
type of like tool
tool tip and a good way to get tool tips
is using
plotly so if you have the time to
actually
um add plotly functions into your your
dashboard it's pretty easy especially if
you're using ggplot
uh because gg plotly has a little
function that can convert ggplot
objects into plotly objects and what i
like about it is you can basically
you know kind of drag around zoom
uh get some little um get some tool kits
so you can see like okay like this guy
is tj dill shaw in 2012 he has an elo of
like 1571.
right that's really cool you also do
some like uh was it filtering so we can
filter where it's only cejudo
uh only some like i don't know
if i double click it so you can see how
there's a lot of like interactive
uh um there's a lot of ways to
work with the data interactively that
the user can use um you can you know
um you can kind of do it as a drag
around
um and all this like interact
interactivity
is very free it's very easy to implement
and
the amount of effort you put into adding
this amount of interactiveness
uh is very cheap right this took me this
is one line of code to convert
an old static gdpot object into
a uh interactive plot with toolkits and
highlighting and
exporting capabilities so uh one of the
so i would definitely say that we should
add a lot of plotly stuff into your
ggplot
um dashboards i mean your shiny
dashboards
but for me since i do a lot of edas i'm
not going to use plotway because
a lot of times on like analysis and
modeling
you don't need this interactiveness
because we're trying to do one certain
goal
and we're not trying to explore anything
we're trying to create a model
or do something very specific uh but for
business intelligence and dashboarding
definitely uh use using plotway is the
way to go
and again i did the same thing with the
distribution right here so you can kind
of see like
right you can um drag and drop um you
can pan
this isn't that useful for a histogram
uh but it's still something that
is kind of nice so another upgrade is i
converted the
uh regular table into a data table so
you can just do some filtering
etc um nothing too crazy
head to head i didn't change anything i
think this is a pretty cool
plot maybe the one thing i changed is
maybe like change this sizing so it's a
little bit more formatted
um i i really wanted to add like the
fire's actual image or profile
but that takes a lot of effort for me to
do that and i just figured that
it's not really worth doing for this
video but if i were to create like a
huge product and deploy it i would
definitely try to look for photos for
each fighter
and have that as a little little profile
photo
and then another thing that added is
just upgrading
um just adding more tabs and upgrading
these plots so
one thing that i like about our shiny
and that makes it kind of stand out
compared to like tableau and power bi is
that we have access to like very
customizable plots
so for this like we can choose um our
weight classes so bantamweight and i'll
just say uh was it
let's do dominic cruz right
so we have like their the name the
height reach
orthodox stance their stance age wins
losses
um and then we have like um
kind of like they're they're um their
offensive metrics so this is like
you know how how many like where are
they uh punching at so
in this case dom dominic cruz is heavily
into
you know um head attacks and stuff like
that we can all switch it to maybe like
like a was that a heavyweight and we can
maybe find
um a heavyweight let's see here
let's see if uh friends
of francis always heavyweights right
seven wins two losses
probably all from knockouts so one thing
that i like to do is just add some very
interesting plots that you wouldn't be
able to create
in uh tableau or power bi
so this is a thing that kind of upgrades
it right i
i think this table is not great i think
i would remove fighter so it'd be a
little bit more cleaner
but that's something where it's just
like general formatting and one thing
that i would probably
change again is just like the size of
this dashboard so it'll fit and be more
consistent
right now it's only just fitting my
screen uh so it's kind of hard to do a
lot of development
but that's just for the the actual like
visual component i think
most people would agree that the
advanced dashboard looks a little bit
nicer than the average dashboard
and definitely looks a lot more nicer
than the basic five minute dashboard
which that's what we would expect
but i think from code wise this
dashboard looks really nice
so one thing that i did was just source
all the functions
um into a helper function r script so
i'm just going to source all this
um basically functionalize a lot of
things that i thought we could change
um so that way it would reduce the
clunkiness of it and
we could edit these functions
independently and kind of encourage
uh function functional development for
our
our dashboard so these are the actual
functions i have like a cleaning
function
i also incorporate reading some csvs and
data in
etc um so that's one thing that kind of
makes the plot a lot cleaner
i think if you just look at the ui part
nothing's really changed but it just
looks a little bit nicer i did some
um formatting where it's like all my tab
items are staggered
um everything kind of matches what we
would expect to see
right so if i was looking at this i
could basically pick out like
i want to look at my fire tab i want to
look at my you know radar chart from
that that tab
um so the ui isn't really different
added some more tabs at just added more
content to it
but nothing fundamentally has really
changed the big thing
that i think makes a good dashboard
especially for development
is just like having things function
uh created as like a function so one
thing they did was i created a helper
uh which will basically load in our uh
our helper functions additionally since
we were always requ
basically redoing these um the uh
basically what is it repeating these
commands so we're always
creating more ego data for each of our
plots we just
had we just created this or converted it
to a reactive
um function this basically allows us to
like hold these things that are being
filtered uh into our global environment
and then use these global features or
like data frames essentially
in our functions so that way we don't
actually have to
uh you know re-run this this function or
create our ego data
and stack all this stuff and do all this
data manipulation uh every time instead
we're just gonna do it once and store it
until we actually change the filter in
this case our filters like our case
sensitivity value
so that makes our my dashboard with the
dashboard
so much faster and it also just makes it
look cleaner
so we have to say like what is crate elo
data like what what's that we just say
oh it's our elo data frame
it's e101 for our first first page
right um i also incorporated some like
cleaning scripts so it's a clean weight
class
uh i kind of like it look um piped in
just because i write a lot of pipes but
if i wanted to make this even cleaner
you know maybe i would even just like
put this and throw it into
uh an actual uh throw it into one of
these
global variables right or i could just
put e01
um inside the actual clean weight cost
function
and we could like remove this this pipe
i think that's pretty
uh uh i don't think there's like a good
convention for it it's just something i
prefer with piping
um so you can see how all these things
are very clean
um i will say one the one thing that i
wish i kind of changed is just converted
these into functions
um but i'm not that good with uh
creating like render objects or just
like
um converting our shiny objects into
functions i know that's how a lot of
people do it
but i really don't do a lot of our shiny
development but i did the best that i
can do with
the things but there's definitely a
thing where
we could just convert this into a
function where the only thing we would
change is essentially the input id
which is definitely very doable that's
one thing that we could uh
improve a little bit but other than that
um let's actually go down here
to our plotly so this is how i actually
created and upgraded my ggplots
um for my dashboard it's just as simply
by
as simple by just saying render plotly
instead of render plot
and then wrapping your ggplot object
with ggplotly
so that amount of work which is about
essentially just two
words that you're doing or two little
commands
will kind of just upgrade your your gg
plots and your dashboards
with the interactiveness and i think it
looks a little bit cleaner
so adding that i think is at like for
the amount of effort it takes just has
so much more value in your dashboards
and then lastly my actual radar plot
plot was
essentially just uh using plotly because
plotly has
oh me look up plot polly.com
so plotly actually has a lot of
different other
um charts that you can create so let me
see if we can
go dash
um so i think plotway is a good or our
probably has a good
um on site if you want to add
in um very kooky kind of weird charts
on that you think the user will really
create like one of the things i use plot
way for is making
3d plots um they're like interactive i
think these are very cool and sometimes
um in my field is not very useful but
i'm sure if you're in like physics or
or something else this would help a lot
for a dashboard that you're gonna
develop
okay let's see here so i think that's
really it for this video
i know it was there's not a lot of code
into it and i know we didn't really go
over um a lot
of the we haven't really gone over um
the tidy tuesday data set um i am
planning on doing that
i i do think i need to make video about
big data so hopefully i can get that out
next week but in the meantime
i'll see you guys next week and tidy on